all right let's do this again last time
we saw something ridiculous the Falk
beer and I'm gonna do something
different here I'm gonna play this d6
move which usually says we're gonna
enter something quiet but this is now
gonna be my follow up this is called and
I think this is deafblind no it is this
is definitely the first time applying
this on stream and maybe even ever I've
had this plate against me in tournament
I'm like a regular over the board
tournament it's called the Philidor
counter gambit and I don't know a whole
lot about it but I know I struggled to
make sense of it when I was playing the
white side so what do you do well I
think trading a little bit would be nice
let's go with that now why do I think
trading might be a good idea because
it's probably the case that white is
gonna have a space advantage right and
that's what we're seeing right now this
is a space advantage and so I'd like to
have a pair of minor pieces off in other
words yeah that's what I meant to say so
now what do you do next
the Philidor counter gambit
all right Knight f3 oh yeah Knight f6
very natural something needs to be done
with this you take I could push the
knight might need to find a new home in
fact it will need to find a new home
also what's annoying is that if the
night plays here to support the pond I
could take maybe I have to be concerned
about ninety five but if if Knight c3 is
played with just this intention to guard
here and now that's what we're gonna be
seeing actually because I could take
Knight takes and then push the night
away and then push the other night away
however I might not want to allow that
to happen actually what about takes here
Knight takes I take here I'm off upon
that seems pretty good
hmm what's the trick here what's the
trick I take here night takes I could if
I could I could push and then push again
but then the knight is able to play to
e5 I don't know if I want to allow that
if I play Knight f6 there might be pawn
takes pawn recapture I'm back on this I
like this let's do this throw the pawn
right in a pin if Knight takes here I
can I actually could just develop
there's no need to take this right away
development this pin is still here it's
hit twice that was hit twice in defended
one so now it's hit three times and
defended once so there's still not a
good way to lend enough support to the
e4 pawn now what else we're gonna see
okay they're having to fight back
timewise and I'm gonna have to look into
this a bit more it's definitely really
interesting and atypical the Philidor
counter gambit interesting okay because
you know it comes off like hey you know
I'm just gonna play a nice little quiet
game and then BAM
at 5:00 I move three I think that'll
catch a lot of people off-guard so I'm
up upon and after this exchange with the
Queens I'll be off the board am i okay
with not having my king castle hmm maybe
I could push this night away first I
actually like that idea let's do this
get out of there night I do weaken this
pond but I would like to have this night
go elsewhere and then maybe just deploy
my bishop here I'm not winning upon by
doing this I'm just assuring myself of
what I'm assuring myself that the
Queen's come off the board but I think
this is most accurate chase that guy way
I'm usually very very reluctant to do a
move like this because it does weaken
the structure and some in some form but
I think this does turn out to be best I
can also do this but I don't want them
to get that pawn back so let me play
here keeping in mind that Queen check is
available but I just have a calm and
well I guess the better word there is
convenient I have a convenient response
to this attack to this check I just
developed and now I'm
to push here or I might want to do this
actually maybe now it's good to get the
Queens off the board
all right let's do this right now I'm
doing this knowing that I have a good
response if Queen takes pawn if Queen
takes pawn I do this and they get the
rook I don't have any other choice but
to recapture he's out of play I have
very little to worry about with regarded
this Knight what's of concern to me is
what this night is gonna do and I'm not
seeing what he could really do that's
great I'm just looking for the last two
accurate moves here do I want to play
rook d8 and when my King gets checked
run in this direction or just develop
with my knight here and if I'm checked I
come over in this direction cuz I don't
I can't rely upon this square and I
think I think actually playing here
right now is best defend this pawn
I really couldn't if there's this rook
check if I play here there's gonna be
Knight takes e5 so I think going in this
direction working myself and getting
myself out of a check and working myself
into another pin is that right there
should be a red flag if you're if you're
playing the black side here and you're
contemplating well if I'm checked I'm
gonna run in this direction what is it
you're really doing with your king one
way to summarize it is you are placing
your king in a pin and right there
that's when you should know something
that's probably something can probably
use some work
no the knight is ready to play here but
and maybe get to this square but I'm not
really afraid of a knight coming here I
think I want to push in the center a bit
I'm only up a pun which isn't really a
whole lot but um maybe this idea of c5
wasn't the greatest thing in the world
but I'm gonna run with it I'll run with
that and I think now is the time to out
push push Knight takes pawn here pawn
takes Bishop Knight lands a fork
Knight lands a fork move this Knight and
you lose I know you know the Bishop's
there to watch over that pun to be
cautious though what do they do less
than a minute less than forty four white
forks this is does not work that is not
a good in-between move to be running
with I remove the threat I guess that
was just missed time issues and that's
it right there's nothing good here
Connor tack hit the rook on the bishop
the bishop needs to come back I'm up a
knight now if Knight check I play here
let's just bump my king up get out of
any silly forks and let's just do this
even though I'm dropping the beep on
king or Knight I'm gonna go with the
night and now I'm defending this pawn
get out of there Knight you need to get
out Forks okay no time good game
interesting the Philidor counter gambit
first time I'm playing that one on
stream let me flip this board here I go
back flip the board and now from White's
perspective the Philidor and now the
filled or a counter gambit this is
almost like the Schliemann defense out
of the Arroyo Lopez but we're not
getting to this Bishop to this knight c6
Bishop b5 move with then f5 it's just
this immediate it's a like an
accelerated Fleeman defense so what's
the what's the big plan I really don't
know I I'm still struggling with it I
never really looked into it enough if
pawn takes then there's pawn takes here
and I'm on the knight
so what do you do is white here anybody
know what the book move is
I don't so I'm really fishing for some
help right now do a lot of fishing right
now I need some help I don't know what's
that what's the move here does anybody
know
can anybody offer any advice in the
twitch chat what is the scoop here what
is it that white should be playing is
there just three moves that somebody is
booked up on three moves here I think
having the next well really two or three
moves is going to be very helpful my
hunch is that you can run with eat takes
F after E for maybe Queen to e2 or what
about D takes D takes E and then after F
takes E you play maybe like Knight to g5
I think there's something to that
actually oh okay thanks I'm getting some
different insight okay okay
all right Knight c3 thanks umm Alex and
the others that have been throwing some
different things there's Knights I'm
thinking I'm so far what was I doing
before I got these different ideas from
the twitch app I was thinking about
different pawn captures but there's
there is Knight c3 it's it's allowing
for the Knights to get kicked around
Knight c3 takes takes d5 Knight here
pawn push night here in fact I think
this is I think this is actually what I
played in that tournament game that I
encountered this and my Knights D got
kicked around I played here and then I
ended up not being able to maintain my
knight or something and I felt a lot of
pressure on the F file so I don't know
yeah okay so anyhow different ideas at
least we're getting here Knight c3 and
Bishop c4 is apparently a Fritz opening
book
move interesting fritz opening book
Bishop c4 and if pawn takes pawn what's
what's the plan from there oh I think
there might be some sneaky tactics I
can't be certain of it but EFT if Bishop
c4 and F takes e I think there might be
Knight takes e5 with the idea if if pawn
recapture Queen out to h5 and then the
king is running for the hills
that might be a sneaky combo right there
but anyhow just at this moment Knight c3
Bishop c4 are apparently different IDs
you could be running with instead the
Bishop comes out we trade a little bit
and you're struggling to try and show
compensation for being up the pond and I
believe you do have some compensation
here you have a lot of development and
my King does have to be cautious of
stuff you are focused in the right
direction these are the weak points but
this this move is not working out so
you're needing to come back I believe
maybe to f1 or b5 I don't know if you
could really avoid or try and go for
giving up two minor pieces for the rook
with Knight takes pawn pawn takes Bishop
and then an eventual fork that could be
another direction you could go in but
anyhow I I learned just a little bit
more by playing this opening right now
the Philidor counter gambit so hopefully
there's a thing or two that you got out
of it as well